the carolina panthers and quarterback
sam darnold a long way to go to get to a
super bowl the panthers desperate to get
a franchise quarterback they tried it
with teddy bridgewater didn't work now
sam darnold met with the media today in
carolina for the first time here he is
talking about his three years with the
new york jets
before the trade happened i always
thought that you know
i could make it work in new york
just being honest
you know i really did and
like i said i mean my goals never
changed even though there was
speculation about me getting traded
i always
you know believed that i could make it
work and um that we were going to get
pieces and
just be able to you know
win some games in new york and go to the
playoffs and eventually win a super bowl
when i heard the news that they wanted
to trade me um
it was tough you know anytime you you're
not wanted somewhere that's always you
know a tough pill to swallow
yeah four years ago this is a guy who
was entering his final year at usc with
the presumption that he could be the top
pick in the 2018 draft he ended up third
overall the jets traded up to get him
gave up three second round picks with
the sixth overall pick to get to three
and take sam darnold they decided after
three years he wasn't the guy and that
has to be a huge blow to the ego and he
talked about that the relief that he
felt when he finally knew what was going
to happen the jets don't want him the
panthers do so now the panthers
see what he has and the reality is he
better show something quickly or they
will fall out of love as fast as they
did with teddy bridgewater we we know
that what's your future sam darden
carolina well talk to teddy bridgewater
and you'll find out because after one
year they may decide to move on from you
and go
roll the dice on someone else to be
their franchise quarterback that's where
the panthers are right now
oh yeah a huge year for sam darnold mike
and you look at the quarterbacks who
potentially but could become available
in 2022 we're talking about aaron
rodgers russell wilson desean watson
depending on what happens with him but
we're talking about big time franchise
quarterbacks i know those guys are older
but do you not think that the panthers
and that owner would not jump at one of
those guys if they got the opportunity
to trade for one of those guys there's
no question unless sam darnold comes out
and does what he didn't do in new york
and become the franchise quarterback
that the jets thought they were drafting
with the third overall pick mike but you
know what the glare's gonna be a lot
less in carolina than it was in the new
york market for sure so he's got a
chance to go and reset and try to get it
done and we've seen it be done like this
ryan tannehill is a perfect example now
he was in miami longer than what darnold
was in new york but he went to tennessee
and hit the reset button and got another
chance and made good on it used to if
your first team the team that drafted
you said
we're moving on that was it for you you
look at all those guys who never got
that second opportunity but sam's
getting a second opportunity just like
ryan tannehill did now it's about making
the most of it and once the panthers
pick up that 50-year option that's
another 18.58 million fully guaranteed
for sam darnold in 2022. he's going to
make about 23 24 million over the next
two years so
shed no tears for the guy who was
rejected by the new york jets because he
landed in carolina with that option
poised to be picked up he would be doing
pretty darn well over the next couple of
years here's matt rule the coach of the
panthers who talked up cam newton last
year and has talked up teddy bridgewater
now here he is talking up sam darnold
which may be i don't know the kiss of
death
we believe in sam we believe in his
skill set we believe in his approach
as you talk to people that
know him he's tough-minded he's
competitive and um
you know we're really hopeful that this
will be a you know
a great place for him
and this will be a tremendous time for
him in his career
matt what physical skills still jump out
to you when you watch sam darnold on
tape despite you know
the documented struggles over the last
three years
um
i think uh when you see his arm talent
his ability to you know i think i don't
think there's a game that you watch
where he doesn't make a play that
makes you say
that you know there it is
i can fit the ball into tight windows
can create with his feet he moves around
a ton
you know he uh
creates plays with his legs extends
plays with his legs
um then you can just kind of see and
feel his grittiness and his toughness so
i think um i think his arm talent his
movement or are a great fit for
the players that we have here that he'll
be playing with
okay he's good enough to play in the nfl
we've seen that have we seen franchise
quarterback traits yet for sam darnold
we haven't or he would still be a member
of the new york jets they had to decide
bird in the hand versus franchise
quarterback in the bush and they're
going presumably with zach wilson in the
hopes that he takes them to that level
where they contend every single year
regardless of what the quality is or
isn't of the supporting cast that's the
quarterback everyone wants sam darnold
to put the supporting cast around and
maybe he'll be good enough shireen
that's what the panthers are banking on
at least for now until that option falls
into their lap to get a true short list
franchise quarterback if it comes next
year or the year after that
yeah i think he's going to get better
coaching where he is now and i think he
has a better cast surrounding him right
now the panthers can use that number
eight overall pick on best available
whoever that is whether it's to help sam
darnold in the offense or to help that
defense but he has weapons mike and and
we know robbie anderson they have a
great connection and robbie anderson had
a career year yet last year he's getting
christian mccaffrey back he's got some
weapons on that offense he's got a
better offensive line than what he has
he's going to have opportunity to show
that he can be that franchise guy that
he thinks he is and the jets at one time
thought he was
meanwhile the carolina panthers continue
to have teddy bridgewater under contract
33 million fully guaranteed given to
bridgewater when they signed him last
year here's rule talking about the
future of teddy bridgewater which
presumably will not be as a member of
the carolina panthers
here it comes trust me
here it comes
i swear i wouldn't lie to you here it
comes here it comes teddy bridgewater
matt roll time i think you guys all know
how i feel about
teddy as a professional um
you know as a person i believe that he
can he can win as a quarterback in this
league i believe that he can move the
ball and do good things
i believe that uh whatever situation he
walks into he's going to walk in with a
great attitude so
but in terms of what will happen i
honestly would have to say you know
we'll have to wait and see how things
play out you know over the coming weeks
um
um you know for him and for us
yeah here's how it's going to play out
it's simple it's simple they're going to
trade him and they're going to cut him
that's how it's going to play out if
they traded they may have to pay part of
the 10 million fully guaranteed that
he's already due to make he's going to
have to agree to take less than the 17
million that he's due to make his salary
this year to facilitate a trade if he
wants to draw a line in the sand and say
i'm not taking a penny less than 17
million he's eventually going to get cut
and the panthers will pay him the
difference between whatever he makes
somewhere else maybe with the buccaneers
at 1.075 million and the 10 million
fully guaranteed he's due to make this
year that's it he's going to be traded
if he's willing to cooperate and there's
a team out there that's willing to
cooperate and the panthers are willing
to pay a little bit of that money or
he's going to get cut it's that simple
they're not paying him 17 million to be
on the roster this year shireen
yeah no question about that we know
teddy bridgewater is moving on somewhere
else and if i'm the panthers i try to
trade him wherever i can outside the
division because there's a good chance
if he gets cut he can go take the
minimum and hey go back to new orleans
go to tampa there's lots of options
there in the division for teddy
bridgewater if he's going to be a backup
he's not going to get a chance to start
somewhere so if i'm if i am the panthers
i want to trade him and i want to trade
him somewhere else i don't want to take
the chance that he's going to come back
uh and beat me and i have some demons uh
left over from from cutting him mike so
i'm gonna trade him wherever i can
outside the division
of course if i don't believe it and then
it's a trade trojan horse like go ahead
play for the buccaneers sure take him
take him sure we we think he's not very
good although i think he's the guy that
he always was i think he was no
different last year than he ever had
been i just think that david tepper the
owner of the team is so intent on
getting a franchise quarterback that
teddy bridgewater is not good enough and
there's a chance a year from now the
conclusion is going to be sam darnold is
not good enough
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports